Everytime I drink something with aspartame
in it, I can't help but worry to myself: AM
I DRINKING CANCER?
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
Artificial sweeteners have been a hotbed of
scientific debate for decades.
There's so much to be said about it -- but
here's a quick roundup of a few things you
should know about the most common artificial
sweeteners.
Saccharin AKA Sweet n Low was the first artificial
sweetener discovered waaay back in 1879 while
scientists were formulating chemical dyes
from coal tar.
I know: YUM!
In the 70s, studies came out finding that
saccharin caused bladder cancer in rats - and
so the government required a cancer warning
on the label.
They tried to take it off the market, but
the diet industry was making big bucks and
weren't gonna have any of that.
Fast forward to the 90s and studies begin
to suggest that the bladder cancer effect
is ONLY in rodents, not humans, and by 2000,
the warning label was removed.
However, the Center for Science in the Public
Interest, which is a non-profit watchdog group,
has saccharin on their "avoid" list.
Saccharin has lost a lot of its popularity
because of the controversy.
The most common artificial sweetener on the
market today is sucralose AKA Splenda.
There's a lot of talk about how Splenda is
unsafe and hasn't been tested...but since
its discovery in 1976, it has been the subject
of over 100 long and short-term animal and
human studies.
And except for a couple highly questioned
studies, no ill effects have been found, so
long as you aren't eating a tub of sucralose
for dinner.
The FDA approved it in 1998 and the CSPI also
agrees it's a safe, non-carcinogenic alternative
to sugar.
Lastly, the biggie: aspartame.
It's found in sooo many products these days,
from to drinks, to candy, gum, jam, processed
foods.
Aspartame came about in the 60's when scientists
were looking for ulcer treatments.
It's been widely studied since then.
The main things you should know is that the
cancer concerns come mostly from a set of
high profile studies done in Italy where they
fed extremely high amounts of aspartame to
rats throughout their lifespan.
The rats developed blood and breast cancers
as well as kidney tumors, which are extremely
rare in the breed of rat used.
However, the FDA and the EFSA both rejected
the studies on the (rather vague) grounds
that they "lacked important data" and approved
Aspartame anyway.
As for studies on people?
The largest study was done by the National
Cancer Institute examining cancer rates in
a half million adults.
Between groups that did and did not consume
products with aspartame, there was no increased
risk of cancer for those that did.
The watchdog group argues that this study
was incomplete: it didn't include the very
elderly, nor people who had consumed aspartame
since childhood.
Aspartame intake was also self reported - which
is a serious flaw when you consider the fact
that a lot of the time people don't know it's
in their food.
The CSPI gives aspartame it's lowest food
safety ranking and argues that it is not safe
for human consumption.
I've read lots of reports out of concern for
my own health, and you should too if you're
interested!
The bottom line seems to be: sucralose is
the safest for regular consumption.
Aspartame and saccharin are more questionable,
so if you're going to consume them, maybe
don't have too much.
Also: if you're using artificial sweeteners
to lose weight, there's a STRONG body of research
that suggests it doesn't help.
In fact, across several large studies done
at Yale for the National Institute of Health:
people who use artificial sweeteners actually
gain weight over time.
They're still trying to figure out why this
happens.
Scientists are also just starting to study
a relatively new artificial sweetener touted
as a "natural alternative to sugar" called
Stevia, or Truvia.
With the limited studies that are out there,
it looks like it could be safe, and the CSPI
statements seem more positive about the potential
for Stevia.
OH MAN.
Lotsa facts today!
Hope this was useful to some of you out there.
I'm gonna put lots of further reading in the
description, check it out, and let me know
what you think about artificial sweeteners
in the comments below.
Thanks for joining me, I'll see you next time!